good morning
Millennials welcome back to the toast
and happy Monday hope everybody's having
a great day thus far hope everybody's
weekends were joyous and weni how was
your weekend Jack joyous and weni I
think are the the exact words I would
use to describe them they were joyous
because there was a lot of joy and it
was wenie because the Wench collection
dropped this morning so I joyous comma
wenie Jo yeah joyous Ampersand weni yeah
um the Wench collection dropped this
morning which is so exciting so my
weekend was weny cuz I was living and
loving life in my new merch the Wench
Miss holiday collection it's available
now at shop toast merch.com Claudia and
I got some gorgeous pics the sets are so
cozy they're so quality if you're
looking for like a cozy set this holiday
season want to treat yourself to one
might I suggest the Wench collection it
is like the that feel of how you want
your set to feel of like the quality and
material it fits good like you look like
you could leave the house in them that's
important in the photo shoot I'm wearing
a size medium Jackie wearing a size
extra large but she said It felt too big
on her so she wish she sized down to a
large yeah because my real size would
have been a medium so I only need to do
one size up yeah so um shopto merch.com
the all the sets are pre-ordered so
you'll be able to get whatever size you
want but we're not going to leave the
pre-order up forever we're going to
close the shop probably tomorrow or
Wednesday so that everybody can get
their orders in and we could start
shipping them out and producing them so
there's not a rush but you know be
mindful of the timing make H make haste
with your merch yeah that's my favorite
thing to say to my husband when he's
like being slow instead of what does it
mean hurry the [__] up love that make
haste my dear husband doesn't it sound
so much better than move your ass slow
[__] love you Zach make haste my dear
husband is definitely something like
people in the Victorian era said to
their husbands when they were being slow
back then they just had a way with words
like there is always a nicer way to say
something actually sometimes I really
like I'll I'll have something to say and
I think on it I sit on it I'm like I
don't know a way to say this without
sounding nasty I mean that's life no I
yeah but I'm just here arguing the
opposite but sometimes there are nicer
more eloquent ways to say something
pointed make haste my dear husband feel
free to use it on yours oh I will
there's definitely you know plenty of
moments I could use that but I also feel
like I have to say it with some sort of
accent make haste my dear husband maybe
like he doesn't know what I'm saying
when I say that he doesn't want to ask
me what it means so he's not making
haste I just feel like with your tone
and like the situation the circumstances
he could deduce what you're trying to
say I agree there must be some deduction
on his part deduction is being done
deduction equals deduced equals
haste how are you my dear TL so I hate
to be like so negative and like down but
like you know this show is it's hard to
do the show when like there are things
going on in your life you know MH so
I've been updating everyone on
um Theo's Journey he's been like having
a lot of health issues me like couldn't
figure it out we thought he had
arthritis I've been like updating
everyone every time I figure something
out and this weekend like he just kind
of like took a turn like he wasn't going
to the bathroom and he would like
couldn't even walk so last night we took
him to um the emergency room
and he they discovered that he has like
a tumor they they keep calling it a mask
they don't really know what it is I have
like no information I didn't even know
if I wanted to talk about it but like
I'm just in such like a bad mood that
like people would be like what the [__]
is wrong with Claudia and so here's
what's wrong with me we were at the
emergency room till 2 a.m. we still
didn't really get a lot of answers he's
there now he'll probably be there for
the next few days but they know that he
has this like tumor Mass structure they
don't think it's benign um it's probably
been like pushing on his leg which has
been causing all that pain and pushing
on his colon which is why he hasn't been
able to poop since
Wednesday
and the good news is that they don't
think it's spread because when they did
the x-rays yesterday there was no
metastasis which is means spreading um
so they're keeping him there today to
biopsy the tumor to get like really
clear ultrasound pictures to make sure
it hasn't spread and like the best case
scenario is that it confirmed hasn't
spread and that it's the type of tumor
that can just be cut
out there's a chance that like maybe it
has spread but it didn't come up in the
X-ray that's not likely which is good um
but there's also a chance that it's just
not the type of tumor that can be just
extracted like the best G scenarios he
just goes in for surgery and they take
it out but some tumors like based on
where they are or their size or what
they're pushing up against some tumors
can't be removed and then you have to go
with like a treatment plan like chemo
which would just be like a really like
long process so like I don't really I
don't know anything so I don't even know
what to share but he's been there since
last night spoke to them this morning
they said he's stable
um I just I don't have a lot of
information but it's like this whole
like last month where we've been just
just trying to figure out what's wrong
with him it appears that this is what it
is but when we did an x-ray 3 weeks ago
the mass wasn't even there so it like
grew really fast right but it also means
you've caught it within 3 weeks yeah
yeah that's true that's good um we're
just trying to look at some bright sze
but this is serious for du and I know
it's been really hard for you guys yeah
um so he's at the Animal Medical Center
and I just like I only heard from them
once I know they're like busy and I'm
not like mad or anything but like I
would love to hear more you know yeah
yeah yeah but they'll call you when they
have
information yeah they said like this
afternoon and like it's like a legit
hospital and they have all these
different departments he's in Internal
Medicine like I have faith in them I
just like first of all was so depressing
last night like the animal hospital in
the middle of the night is like one of
the saddest places to be on the planet
yeah and it felt like
like our news was like the worst news in
the room you know I was just like
comparing people's
reactions don't lose your tury spirit
like no one was no one was crying except
for us well it was a lot they just said
it's like so uncommon and it's so
alarming cuz he's only six like yeah
yeah dogs have health issues but like
the6 yeah well hopefully it's as you
stated the best case scenario which is
removable not
spreaded let us pray for that yeah like
I don't know what I will do if it's like
not that if it's like he has to have
chemo like I'll I'll literally like I'll
kill myself like I will don't think like
that that's a problem for another day
yeah don't stress about things that
aren't in your on your plate yet so my
phone is on in case they call so we'll
just have to cut that but that's fine of
course like they said they would call in
the morning with like a morning update
I'm on my phone all morning I literally
go to take a piss oh I mean always and
then they call and I didn't have the
right extension so I'm like calling a
million different numbers men wanted to
kill me at least for me they always say
they'll call in the morning whenever
it's like something and it's always
during the toast and it's an unknown
number so I don't pick it up no they
were like we'll call between 9:00 and
11: I'm like oh okay yeah no I'm just
like busy during those times but it's
fine no keep your phone on that's
totally fine we're do strong I'm looking
at my do
pillow no like he h absolutely has to be
okay like the other like good news is
that because they did all these tests
they did blood work they did full body
X-rays and it's not like this is a sick
dog his heart is really strong his liver
is really strong his kidneys look good
his blood work came back mostly good
like this isn't you know a dog that's
very ill yeah and also now you know
what's really ailing him like
misdiagnoses are so frustrating so
frustrating treating him for arthritis
they don't even think it's arthritis
he's just in a lot of pain this tumor is
like blocking his ability to walk right
so at least now he will get the answers
that he needs he'll get the medicine
that he needs and that is good yeah no
they put him on pain meds but like when
we when they started the x-rays cuz he
had to lay on his back and honestly he
was like so sad his like tongue was
hanging out of his mouth he there was no
life behind those eyes but like this is
probably the first time he hasn't been
in an extraordinary pain in like a month
yeah and like he didn't even complain to
his mommy you know because he's so
strong he know he's so strong and he
needs to stop I know you have to be
strong for him now I know it's just like
the
waiting yeah well that's why the toast
distracts that's what we do yeah no and
I'm I'm actually glad like to get out of
the house and to get your mind off it
for a few we have a some we have some
good stories today I'm not I'm I feel
good about them okay and other than this
late night Sunday night bad news how was
your
weekend it was good I don't even really
remember like what happened before that
but it was just like a nice weekend at
home I read I'm reading iron flame it's
very long I've been reading for like a
month it's you know I'm at 30% okay I'm
at 16% and I read a little every night
but I tell on a little I can tell you
like I'm up to 30% like nothing has
happened since I was at
16 great I just like get too tired but I
also like don't start reading till 10:30
so no wonder I'm tired it's bedtime I've
also heard that like the book is
confusing in terms of like the World
building and like the rules and the
magic and the wards and the venin Oh I
thought we were done with that no me too
I thought I was like oh I understand
basca now like now I can dive into the
second book like totally understanding
this world that we've been building thus
far also has anyone pointed out that Nar
are like where they live is also the
cheerleading troop nobody has but I've
obviously thought of that as well I'm
like why do I know Navar yeah that's
interesting I saw a hilarious Tik Tok in
the redheads chat we all chat and send
each other about the parit no I don't
know why that didn't make me laugh so
much it was of someone like roasting the
writer for like the writing of this book
she like did one sentence
and yeah it's not grammatically correct
I am rereading that's for sure lots of
passages oh but also I did a little bit
more research on them adapting it into
it is a movie but it's Amazon Studios so
I thought it would be like a TV show and
I think it's Michael B Jordan's
production company so now a lot of
people are saying Michael B Jordan could
be Xander Zaden oh sorry he's just a
little old I know that's the only thing
he is like aged out a bit Yeah but I he
does have like what they say Zaden is
like super hot does that mean that my B
Jordan red fourth
Wing that's a good question you know cuz
I was just watching an interview with
Brie Larson about lessons in chemistry
and she said they that she had like the
role and she optioned the book before it
even came out so like sometimes you're
with it from the very beginning and
sometimes you just like uh I feel like
you take advantage of of a moment like a
moment and the momentum so she read the
book before it came out and then wanted
to be in the movie like she was on the
project before the book even came out so
how do you even know know a book's going
to be popular well you know it's going
to be chosen for Reese or Oprah or Jenna
and like it is a machine when you hear
when you learn about the publishing
industry it's like very no I have I
forget who I was saying this to under
lock and key like they've got it on lock
I said this on the toast but then I had
like oh no I said it on the toast
Goodreads is an industry plan like oh
they're a part they're a part of this
they're a part of this you think
conspiracy for sure I just feel like not
holding they're not doing a good job as
an injy plant because they don't
actually give good suggestions no that's
what I'm saying they prop up books by
certain authors by certain publishing
houses that are going to be made into
movies like you can if you have good
reads on your side like your book sucks
it doesn't even matter like your book
will be a success yeah I guess yes we've
had this conversation but I just feel
like they know I like historical fiction
and they're always recommending like to
Kill a Mocking
Bird no totally who does that serve like
who's making money on to kill a mocky MD
today Kim H is that the guy who
wrote I don't who wrote to killer
Mocking Bird I don't know and I just
want you guys to know I don't I don't
don't I haven't read to Kill a Mocking
Bird like I probably was supposed to at
one point who it har one more time
Harper Harper Le oh okay I'm thinking of
K poek who wrote
um that book Ben likes I'll Google
it K poek oh my God I have a voicemail
how the [__] did I miss that oh my God
maybe your phone thought it was spam the
chosen yeah yeah yeah oh I'm sorry no it
was someone else okay thank god oh tury
no my phone didn't even [__] ring you
it's on
ringer no it's on vibrate put it on
ringer put it on yeah just hopefully you
don't get if I get a text I don't want
to it's fine I'm fine okay they probably
shouldn't they like God God willing they
should call they're not going to call
till like much later today yeah it's
like a watched phone never rings no of
course not but you got to take a piss oh
it's ringing off the hook yeah yeah
what were we talking about books Iron FL
iron flame yes so we're both not really
making progress but I will finish it
before I start the next redheads book
which is the woman and Me by Britney
Spears read along with us this month my
I will finish it before I start my book
club book which is Matthew Perry's book
um so we're both in like our celebrity
Memoir era and with Thanksgiving this
weekend I'm probably going to have a lot
of time to read so I feel confident that
I'll finish both books by the end of the
week and then speaking of today and
tomorrow are our only shows so if you're
looking for us we are here Monday
Tuesday of this week Wednesday through
Friday we are off for Thanksgiving but
of course there will be podcast episodes
dropping on our patreon we have three
episodes left three days this week
without toast you got it you'll get it
so if you're Desperado patreon.com toast
1 plus one equals toast patreon
patreon.com theeast I couldn't have said
it better myself speaking of this week
it's Thanksgiving which is really
exciting one of the better holidays
agreed how are you feeling about
Thanksgiving right now I'm feeling
like I'm hoping by Thursday like I have
something to be thankful for you know
yeah oh please tury Lou no I just mean
when it comes with you I know I'm like
so grateful I have an amazing life
that's not what I was saying please like
don't Comfort my neck right now
um I it's just hard to focus on really
anything I understand well but I do love
Thanksgiving I love Thanksgiving I've
got to start plotting my menu printing
out my recipes doing my
shop very very excited I've got some new
table wear coming shopping for table
Tings table top plates Chargers not
charging on my iPad chargers there's
just I want it all tury I want it all
that's what I was saying last week about
that new Craton bowel store in the city
oh my God there's this collection of
like plates from uh William
Sonoma and I just I want them all I want
every plate I want every Bowl every
salad plate everything like what do I do
and the thing is it's not even a sort of
thing where I could just buy a couple
maybe I could buy like four four big
dinner plates and have my pasta on them
at night but I need the whole thing like
what do I do of course it's a collection
for a reason I want to write into de
toasters what do I do I need the whole
thing but I don't need it I know I wish
I was like getting married and I could
register for it oh I definitely like
would redo my registry but that's just
like that's life you know yeah no there
are so many things that I didn't have on
my registry that I should have that I
had that I didn't need but overall in
terms of like the plates that I
registered in my China like I did good
yeah no same I'm not unha I would do it
different differently now I would just
add more on this collection from William
Sonoma yeah maybe William Sona wants to
be a sponsor perhaps that would solve my
problem it would that's what I we would
tell the deer toaster start a podcast
Rave about William Sonoma and pray that
they reach out yeah I just need like a
little credit a big credit but yeah um
no shopping for home wear like really is
so fun and then you like get back to
your house and it's like kind of depress
ressing cuz you're like I could never
like pull all this off no it's like no I
could pull it off but then would be
sitting next to like my ugly other stuff
no and then there's like life you know
you have to like keep all like the
actual crap you use every day it's like
crap crap next to your gorgeous New
China like no one's house is really like
that you know and that makes me feel
better like all the [__] you see on TV
and Instagram like gorgeous homes like
no those are sets like people have real
lives they have kids they have dogs like
their houses need to look a certain like
way no like if you have a baby like
where there's your drying rack that
[__] drying rack is so ugly what
drying rack so like you have it's like a
little rack you can there's a million
kinds but like where the bottles like
finish drying right right right where
the
P where is the Rock plus the
sterilizer which not everybody needs you
could do it in the dishwasher or on the
stove but it's just like where are your
things my friend no that's the thing
like remember when like keep in mind
when you're like sring Instagram or
looking at inspo like those people's
things aren't there they're behind the
camera yeah it's about chki Nation yeah
you know what I got by the way what I
got your veggie
Chopper and well no I just ordered it
last night cuz I I want it for
Thanksgiving meal prep you need it like
it'll we made a chili on Friday and
it'll like it made it cut down the prep
time more than half if you made a chili
and didn't post about it did you even
make a chili question Mar well I did
make a chili and did post about it but I
post about it on Tik Tok because the
last time me and Ben made a chili people
like were giving us so much crap about
putting rayo's homemade tomato sauce in
our chili they're like that's a meat
sauce and you know Rayo saw that and
your girl got a sponsorship so oh my God
yeah we posted the chili on our
sponsored video on Tik Tok feel free to
check it out addressing the controversy
oh my gosh William Sonoma William Sonoma
William
Sonoma yeah so um
William Sonoma William and Sonoma
Pottery
Barn Craton
Barrel outer outdoor furniture what the
hell is that these outdoor furniture
that I need I think I'm going to get on
Black Friday I've been like wait I've
really been plotting my outo Black
Friday I've been trying to make a Black
Friday plan cuz it always catches me
underwears and I decided for this Black
Friday I'm going to get my outdoor
furniture because Furniture is so
expensive and I'm going to uh shop the
sales that's smart I the only thing I
like kind of need right now I'm so
annoyed I didn't even realize it when I
went to Athens I left my Kindle Oasis on
the
plane so that's been really tough for me
I have another Kindle but it's huge we
got it as a gift remember those
bedazzled ones oh I'm sorry I thought
that's what you were talking about no no
no that's my Kindle that doesn't leave
the house it's huge I couldn't travel
with that the Oasis is so light I love
it it has that grip on the back it's for
travel I lost it I'm so upset and I'm
just happy for the person who's going to
pick it up and find a whole ass Library
a whole ass library of dirty books no i'
like smut and some Holocaust books in
there as well hes dirty books so I just
Amazon do Black Friday like I know they
have their Prime day they have their
Prime but I feel like I feel they they
definitely get in on Black Friday sales
they're not going to let that pass them
by so I was going to order it I'm like
let me just wait see if it goes on sale
that was so annoying that is annoying
but I thought you lost your your custom
scribe no no no no that one doesn't
leave the house it's so big yeah yeah
yeah okay an oasis sad yet replacable
sad unfortunately but yes yes
replaceable and that Kindle and I have
been through a lot like the day I got it
I was so excited about it on Prime day
it was like on Amazing sale that day Ben
put it through the wash and you know
what it survived oh that's cool I think
Zach put my airpods through the wash the
other day and they survived they're
survivors ain't that the
truth what El going to get for Black
Friday the thing is like I I've I need
so much furniture for my new place but
I'm not like settled yet on like the
what you're going to get what I'm going
to get but hopefully in the next couple
of days I can like settle it so I can
take advantage I also need some outdoor
furniture yeah so outer outdoor
furniture
manifesting but you know it needs to be
manifested by Friday because I'm going
to like I've decided you're going to
pull the trigger so many times we're
like playing in the backyard I don't
have a seat out I don't have a chair not
a a lounge a shake
a stool so I want to get one of their
couches they were on Shark Tank oh yeah
it's very what's the best Shark Tank
purchase you've ever
made well there it's to full because
it's like did I buy it because it was on
Shark Tank or I bought it and it
happened to have been on Shark Tank at
one point that's like ho you bought it
because it was on Shark Tank
oh I haven't bought like that many
things straight away from the episode
the last thing I bought I think were
those Kudos diapers and good but then um
you know my life got upside down we
moved to New York I left the Kudos and
my subscription at home and by the time
we got back all the ones that were
delivered Harry was no longer those size
right I have bought you're right there's
a lot of products I have that just
happen to be on Shark Tank like of
course like a Scrub Daddy coal 87 pizza
that's the
best I don't know I I have watched an
episode in purchase like I purchased
this thing for my posture okay it's like
this harness
sucked um I've
purchased
Z would be better for this conversation
he doesn't miss an episode Olivia too is
obsessed with Shark Tank yes she is she
is they should do an episode about Shark
Tank they should beond the tank beyond
the toast yeah that's the best part of
the Shark Tank episodes beyond the tank
like seeing like the actual long success
yeah cool all right enough about shark
tank without further ad do enough about
a show that isn't ours H totally with
but the sharks have contributed to the
show by all coming on yeah Kevin has
come on Barbara's come on I think that's
it Damon oh Damon yes
um that's it yeah okay Lori Robert
Mark it's good to have goals I'm
surprised we haven't had Lori she's so
toasty yeah and of course like whenever
you're watching an episode a part of the
experiences to turn to the person you're
watching it with and be like if you were
on who would you want and honestly like
ideally I would pick like a team of two
but if I had to really just choose one
depending on what it is but I think I
would choose Lori oh I mean cuz for our
Tings it would probably be Lori but if
you were like you know the average
person man or woman I the dream is to
have Mark and Lori because I feel like
they're both the most successful and
they both cover different things like
Lorie's very like female focused with
like products for the home but she also
has this massive Network she's huge in
retail she's huge for like B to C you
know yeah what about Kevin but Mark I
the thing is I don't think I would ever
come to a good deal with Kevin like he's
a a a tiger a shark and you know I think
the other two are a little bit more
accommodating yeah I used to feel that
way about Mr Wonderful but now I'm like
yeah you got to be this is business
yeah this isn't the playground yeah so
now without further Ado About to show
that isurus here are the fast D stories
that you need to know and the fast five
stories that you need to know are
brought to you by the farmer's
dog I'm okay okay the results of
switching your dog's food from kibble to
Fresh can seem like magic when a senior
dog starts acting like a puppy again and
the pickiest of eaters can't wait for
dinner time you might think that some
spells were cast but the farmer's dog
doesn't use any sorcery or secet
ingredients to make their fresh food
just science the farmer's dog makes and
delivers fresh healthy dog food it's
developed by vets it's nutritionally
balanced and it's made from real healthy
ingredients to human food safety
standards it's the best options for dog
option for dogs at all life stages
because it's not kibble and it's not
canned goo it's just real healthy food
traditional dry and wet dog food options
are highly processed they can use much
lower quality ingredients than they
claim to and they are extremely
difficult to portion accurately the
farmer's dog isn't just fresh higher
quality food they also send the food
pre- portion specifically for your dog
based on their unique nutritional needs
this makes it easy to help your dog
maintain their ideal weight which is one
of the biggest indicators of a full
healthy life dogs at all Health dogs at
healthy weight can live up to two and a
half years longer than overweight dogs
um a fresh diet has been found to have
all sorts of benefits from healthier
coat to skin better breath even easier
digestion and smaller better poops a
healthy diet isn't just important for
humans so whether your dog is struggling
with bowel movements with breath with
energy there's really never a bad time
to switch to fresh healthy dog food from
from the farmer's dog so it doesn't
matter if your dog is old or young it's
always the right time to begin investing
in their health helping you live more
healthy happy and full years together
that means more magical moments with
your dog but no actual magic is required
get 50% off your first box of fresh
healthy food at thefarmersdog.com toast
plus you get free shipping when you go
to thefarmersdog.com toast go to
thefarmersdog.com toast to get 50% off
your first box and free
shipping thank you la you're welcome fa
our first Story Taylor Swift took the
ARs tour to Brazil this weekend and with
some
tragic
um effects so Taylor's fans begged for
water during the Brazil concert where
extreme temperatures caused one Swifty's
death during Taylor's first night in Rio
de Janeiro a sea of fans were subjected
to dangerous conditions which led to one
concert Go's death after standing in
line for hours to get inside the stadium
and claim a good spot in the General
Admissions area Ana Clara Benavides
fainted and had to be resuscitated at
the stadium for about 40 minutes
according to a Brazilian newspaper she
suffered a second cardiac rest on the
way to the hospital dying shortly after
her her arrival following news of her
death other fans who were present for
the concert gave insight into the
terrible conditions via social media in
videos posted to X um a sweat dren
tailor could be seen pausing her set to
urge staff members to administer water
bottles to concert goers who were
chanting for it in the middle of all too
well she grabs water from someone off
stage and throws it into the crowd
there's video of her like H like
red-faced breathing very heavily in
between um lyrics it was just kind of a
disaster um she put out a statement
about the Swifty who passed away saying
I can't believe I'm writing these words
but it with a shattered heart that I say
we lost a fan earlier tonight before my
show I can't even tell you how
devastated I am by this there's very
little information I have other than the
fact that she was so incredibly
beautiful and far too young I'm not
going to be able to speak about this
from stage because I feel overwhelmed by
grief when I even try to talk about it I
want to say now I feel like this loss I
feel this loss deeply and my broken
heart goes out to her family and friends
this is the last thing I ever thought
would happen when we decided to bring
this tour to Brazil then on her last
night in Brazil she for surprise song
she saying bigger than the whole Sky
which was clearly it's a song about
grief it's a song about death like it's
clearly dedicated to
Anna um so this whole Rio concert was
kind of like a [__] show so apparently
they're experiencing a heat wave in Rio
it's like 107 degrees but inside the
stadium they closed the vents at the top
of the stadium so it was more like 130°
inside the stadium so it really was like
people aren't being dramatic like it was
ungodly um Taylor didn't look okay
nobody in the stadium was okay and then
Rio like outside the stadium has like an
an enormous crime issue so people were
being like held up at gunpoint like
being robbed in these big uh crowds so
it was just kind of a mess top to bottom
um she postponed the second show it was
supposed to be the night after this
event um the Heatwave was still in full
effect I think she postponed it like 2 3
days and then it was last night um it
appeared to be better they opened the
vents water was more accessible um I'm
sure Taylor is devastated I'm sure she's
back home already I'm sure she wanted to
get out yeah um just like chaos yeah so
so horrible like when you so sad are a
young person going to an entertainment
event like that's just the last thing
that you expect to happen and from I saw
some things about like this stadium in
like it was so mismanaged by the stadium
like the like they said Taylor should
have never performed at this particular
Stadium it's like known to be very janky
and there's other facilities in the
country that would would facilitate it
better right and when there's a heat
wave like why do you close the vents you
don't no that's insane yeah and is there
general admission in was there general
admission in the US no so this is
something that's happening in some of
the stadiums that are um International I
don't know if it's like it's a stadium
thing or it's a tailor thing but I think
it just has to do with the particular
stadiums GA in a stadium that's I don't
agree I don't think that's like the best
and in a heat way it's just a a recipe
for what was a
disaster yeah because and also I'm
thinking like if some people could
barely like stand to watch how is Taylor
up there in the seat doing three hour
show yeah no like it's dangerous for
everyone yeah and I feel like our girl
is like people commend her for her work
ethics so much like through the rain
like there's nothing she won't perform
through
and I feel like she shouldn't have done
this show how was she to know it's kind
of no but it's also just like it's such
a double-edged sword like if she cancels
when like she has canceled like a few
shows like she just did it in Argentina
like there's lightning she does it for
the safety of everyone and she gets so
much [__] when she does and you know
it's understandable like people travel
they paid money but like at the end of
the day safety trumps everything yeah so
like it's like a lose lose situation for
her because when she cancels she gets so
much backlash really yeah like the
Swifty Community is like so mad
always well maybe after seeing this
they'll understand the next cancellation
a little better right you right that's
just that's just what happens when you
do stadiums like you are subjected to
the elements yes yeah and so you have to
monitor it and so her postponing the
second show was obviously necessary yeah
and that video of her like struggling to
breathe I can only imagine what people
down in the in the crowds were were
feeling yeah and she's wearing like so
many layers of like tights and boots and
Spar she working so hard yeah no
horrible yeah very very sad um our next
story is some better tailor news okay
because Travis Kelce is doing a did a
wide- ranging interview with wsj
magazine have you seen it and he's
talking all about how him and Taylor got
together oh my God no I haven't seen
this it came out this morning so in a
new wide- ranging interview for the
cover of wsj Magazine's December January
issue Travis is explaining just how his
relationship with Taylor began he said I
don't know if I want to get into all of
it he said during the discussion before
ultimately reflecting on his
unsuccessful first attempt to Meet the
Musician at her era tour show in July he
previously shared that during an episode
of new heights now there's some more
details quote there were definitely
people she knew that knew who I was in
her Corner who said yo did you know he
was coming I had someone playing Cupid
he told the outlet adding that he
eventually found that out from tailor
when she contacted him directly oh she
contacted him directly he said quote she
told me exactly what was going on and
how I got lucky enough to reach out to
her he told wsj magazine a few members
of the Swift family even assisted in
helping get her attention quote she'll
probably hate me for saying this but
when she came to Arrowhead they gave her
the big locker room as a dressing room
and her little cousins were taking
pictures in front of my locker no I'm
broken as for their first time meeting
he got candid and said quote when I met
her in New York we had already kind of
been talking so I knew we could have a
nice dinner and like a conversation and
what goes from there will go from
there this is just like so crazy how
much we know yeah wait he also said
sorry that um he's never dated anyone
like Taylor before with that kind of
aura about them he's never dealt with it
like the attention and everything but at
the same time I'm not running away from
any of it the scrutiny she gets how much
she has a magnifying glass on her every
single day Paparazzi outside her house
outside every restaurant she goes there
after every flight she gets off and
she's just living enjoying life when she
acts like that I better not be the one
acting all strange no it's so true there
are very few people who are like built
for that life but literally Travis Kelce
is one of them like I feel like nothing
bothers him everything just like rolls
off his back I don't think he gets
bogged down by like what Twitter says
about him I think it's of course for me
everything comes back to the song Piece
that's literally about this type of Life
Taylor has and how it's really not for
everyone would it be enough if I could
never give you peace whoever's going to
be with Taylor like they will never have
peace like you can't even go on vacation
without being tortured right so it might
as well be someone who would have that
regardless of Taylor or no Taylor well
no he wouldn't but it might as well be
someone who can have fun with it who
doesn't take it so seriously and I think
that the fact that she wrote piece while
she was with Joe was a reflection of the
fact that like it wasn't enough for him
and she probably knew that deep down
right but like it helps that you know
Travis Kelsey when he walks through a
restaurant like people are gawking and
taking pictures on for sure but not on
the level she's not talking about just
Fame she's talking about like something
else Joe had to get used to you know not
being able to walk through a restaurant
Incognito anymore no but also like Joe
had to get used to the fact like he was
known and he's accomplished for sure
he's known as Taylor st's boyfriend a
lot of us only know who he is know his
name and of you know what he looks like
because he's Taylor boyfriend whereas
like Travis Kelsey you're right on his
own like has that sort of he gets that
reception now it's on a completely new
level yeah but yeah I Travis even just
his size like he never walks
anonymously anywhere and I do feel like
not to you know always bring it back to
this but I feel like she's kind of like
been healed like I feel like for so long
she would there are very few songs she's
never played and she's never played
piece and I feel like we all just kind
of understood that like she never would
because it's so personal and it's so
real and it ended up being true the the
the line of the song is would it be
enough if I could never give you peace
and it turned out that it wasn't enough
well do you know BR broke up do we know
who broke up with who no but I have to
imagine I have to imagine you know this
whole conversation was a part of it you
know yes wait there were two more things
that I wanted to share from the article
he also called her wait but no sorry
what I was going to say was like I now
feel like her singing piece like is a
possibility cuz it's like she's been
healed you know yeah he I just don't
know what in the acoustic set how you
play piece like alone on a guitar or
alone on piano if you listen to the
track it's like a very kind of
futuristic weird like track Taylor would
have figur it out a coming like just
know if I hear a coming of Ages coming
on on someone's [__] live stream like
I will die I will die Kelsey also called
Swift both hilarious and the genius and
revealed that he and she share a similar
Outlook family and work he said
everybody knows I'm a Family Guy her
team is her family her family does a lot
of stuff in terms of the tour the
marketing being around so I think she
has a lot of those values as well which
is right up my alley that to me is like
a very important factor in this
relationship because I think that like
he wants a family of his
own and I think that you know everything
that they're doing they are on the path
to marriage 100% And Children nope 100%
they'll be the tallest kids on the
planet does Taylor want
children I think so okay I don't know if
she's ever outright said it but she's
such romantic through all of her music
everyone knows what she like thinks and
feels no that's true I mean I guess if
you if you listen to her music she
really like is very traditional you know
yeah she's always been like a hopeless
romantic I'm sure a family is something
that she wants and a lot of people
speculate that bigger than the whole sky
is actually a song about a miscarriage
yeah so I have to imagine that that
that's something that she wants yeah
especially because she loves her M and
her siblings like family is so important
to her and also sometimes it takes being
with the right person to want those
things yeah um and just like the fact
that he sits down in all these
interviews and he talks about Taylor but
he also talks about other stuff like
knowing that I have to imagine that all
of everything he's saying is like
sanctioned by Taylor like she's okay
with him sharing um that's just so
different from anything we've
experienced yes but I also feel like
it's not like he runs by her what he's
going to say so I feel like she reads
something something like this and it's
like he likes me he really likes like
you know she's seeing she obviously
knows I'm sure he tells her these things
but like to have someone gush about you
publicly it's like they also are still
human beings if you saw a guy that you
like like talking about you positively
like this like I'm sure it makes her day
especially when you just got out of a
six-year relationship that was so
private because the person you were with
wanted that privacy like Joe was not
wanting to do red carpets I think he was
like nervous about his career being
Taylor Swift's boyfriend and he became
that anyway so he might as well have
just milked it yeah but like Travis is
very confident and he's very proud and I
think that that confident must make her
happy even if she knows he's doing the
interview and she knows what things he's
allowed to say like that's really like
you know nice to see the guy that you
like gushing about you and speaking like
so flatteringly of you no and honestly
I'm sure this has been like a very
challenging week for Taylor and like you
were saying these are two people who
have just been having a lot of fun and
it's all been very positive they really
haven't been through tough times but
part of being in a relationship is you
know you know having a life partner when
life gets hard and this has probably
been a really hard week for Taylor yeah
and I think that their relationship will
probably grow immensely during this time
you need to lean on someone when you're
grieving yeah I Travis will be there for
her and tonight is the big eagles Chiefs
game a lot of people think that like
that's going to be the matchup in the
Super Bowl Taylor was supposed to be at
this game apparently there were reports
that Andrea Swift was coming she was
going to meet Donna Kelce I'm sure
that's all change now because the shows
were postponed she might still be in Rio
I doubt she is but um I I'm sure shees
want to be seen publicly for like a few
days yeah yeah um I'm sure the NFL is
upset about about that for them because
they literally the ratings will be huge
anyway no but they literally did all of
this like because they're being thirsty
and the Kelsey both like yep the whole
thing is just a little thirsty because
they're both in they wouldn't be playing
each other in their conferences until
the Super Bowl but apparently they like
is that true yeah they're CU they're in
different conferences this game was like
made up the NFL like kind of puts on
random games like a scrimmage I guess
and that's what this is it's just like a
showcase so it doesn't count towards
like no because they're in different
conferences that's why they only played
each other in the Super
Bowl are you sure posit well as positive
as I could
be who ask Taylor no I'm gonna ask
Taylor donni Ben is like
not say is this Eagles Chiefs game like
a fake game is this Eagles Chiefs game
tonight a part of the regular schedule
question mark like does it count towards
their season season question mark would
these two teams be playing each other
any year question mark or is the NFL
just putting it on for fun basically or
is the NFL just putting it on for fun
basically I'm protecting my family and
my interests it's literally that scene
in Kardashians where she's like fighting
with Kanye and Chloe Courtney's Chloe's
telling her what to say and she's like
me and my
family yeah know it's like it uh like
I'm in your ear you're on a date and
like I'm telling you what to say
literally let me know what she says but
she said LOL like hello answer me it's a
regular season
game she's
typing okay so I'm even though one is in
NFC and one is in AFC right okay so it
counts do they normally not play each
other why are they playing each other
why
now cuz NFL is thirsty that's why no but
I feel like you like they would never
play each other ever during the season
no NFC
AFC she needs to type faster I feel like
you need to just call
someone
yeah if her next answer like doesn't
please me I'll call her okay hopefully
she pleases
you I'm so hungry what are you going to
have for
lunch just cuz like I'm I'm going
through something hard like I think I
deserve like a big fat lunch I think you
deserve a comfort meal you could say
yeah to be comforted so the options are
endless
pizzer
pasta what should I have for
lunch because she's typing a lot I'm
telling you it's
complicated it's not straightforward I
feel like it is no it's not it's
thirst it's thirst disguised as
something productive for the season okay
I guess we can move on and when she
answers I'll let you know okay anyways
yes they have their big game I know like
you know Kelsey bow plus the Swift of it
all the parents were supposed to meet um
now it's just about Kelsey B which is
also exciting an NFC will typically play
most games against other NFC teams but
teams will always play three or four
games outside of their division just to
keep it in interesting and who decides
who plays who for that and why no you're
right okay so like it's it's not like it
wasn't like legally allowed to happen
but they pushed you know yeah they're
making [__] up they're making [__] up
wait also totally separately um I don't
know if you've like noticed anything
different about me I know your gray
Grandma nails are out the door and you
have this maroon I got red nails you
don't understand every manicure for the
history of my life like I always get
Jackie like hates it she always makes
fun of me it's like beige or nude it's
like skin tone I don't like to like draw
a lot of attention to my hands because I
don't like my hands they're like wrinkly
and fat but yesterday it was just like
such a beautiful fall day and I was like
you know what like I'm going to [__]
[__] up and like do maroon like burgundy
so I thought about it for a while I did
the decision I have burgundy Nails I
feel like it makes my hands look so pale
yeah but it looks nice I think it does
too I'm like kind of like obsessed with
it this is box blood from the brand CN D
shellac it looks
nice every time I do like I have that
feeling every fall too and I get like a
red nail and I regret it well when when
it was getting it literally happens
every year and then I see on my time hop
like oh this week last year I also like
decided to get red and I'm like do I
ever change or am I just the same you
know what I mean like it's human nature
it's like when you wear the same outfit
today as you did on Time Hop a year ago
and buy like full outfit not just like a
sweatshirt like you the ex
on the exact same day
like while I was getting the manicure
done I was leading a life of regret
because red nail polish just like stains
your skin so like when she would get a
little polish on my skin which is normal
and you normally would take acetone like
it leaves like a red mark so I did leave
with like bloody hands but then I took a
bath and it all went away and now I'm
just looking at it and like I don't know
who this girl is like I look down at my
hands and it's giving Freaky Friday you
know yeah it's like you changed with
snitch I just like I like it I think
think I do uh because you like it yeah
cool no I kind of love it are you ready
for our next story oh yeah we're done
talking about my nails yeah yeah I just
feel like we're moving slowly oh yeah
what story are we at three okay okay
this is exciting news Suki Waterhouse
announced she's pregnant and is
expecting her first baby with Robert
Patterson so it's exciting but it's re
like nobody talks about how hard it is
to see other people living your dream
like I am happy for them of course which
part is your dream having Robert
patson's baby yeah yeah yeah and just
like Robert patson loving you and
wanting to impregnate you you know yeah
no I'm sure that's hard for you she's
also a singer so like she really is
living your dream who knew she was a
singer I did she had such a viral song
on Tik Tok you think we're the same the
skyline Falls as I try to make sense of
it all it went so viral and then like I
saw a video of her performing it and I
was like what this is her well it's her
she's pregnant with Edward's baby and
they're going to name it
renez uh she revealed that at a concert
in Mexico City on Sunday she said I
decided to wear something particularly
sparkly today cuz I thought it might
distract you from something else that's
going on while gesturing to her stomach
she said I'm not sure if it's working I
love these two like I think they're the
greatest couple of all time like they're
so good-looking they're so in love
they've been together forever they went
to the ARA tour like there's just
there's so much here they also look
alike if you swap their hairs they look
the same so their baby is going to look
just like them it's giving reneesme like
it's seriously giving reneesme no I love
them as well I'm really happy for them
and I'm happy for rubber patson like he
just no and honestly like if it couldn't
be me I'm happy it was her yeah yeah
also her sister is in the show I'm
watching Buccaneers it's filled with
nepo babies the show I didn't even know
she had a sister who was like in the
industry yeah now that her name's imagin
Waterhouse they've got cool names yeah
they do imagin and you know who else is
in the show who no you don't know oh my
God imagin Waterhouse is literally
gorgeous I could die that's her role
she's like the gorgeous
debutant okay and who else Kate
Winslet's
daughter what's her name I don't know
any like I don't remember but um now
that I heard she was Kate wi her yeah
she Mia threet she does look like Kate
Winslet she does actually she wait does
she also have like a freckle above her
lip oh my God she does yes that's crazy
no yeah do you think that like it's
real yeah no I just zoomed it on a
picture like it's a full-blown yeah no
and it's in the show too but like what
are the odds no
that's literally
crazy does that mean my baby will come
out with a big old mole on his face
you'll have Dr gey right there God I
hope not um so happy for the happy
couple we'll keep you a breast this is
like we don't always support like
pregnancy news but this is just this
just means these two are bound for for a
while yeah know and these are just like
two people who are such artists and so
like non traditional so for them to just
like be settling down and having a baby
like I'm obsessed yeah me too
our next story are you ready for it mhm
Kim Kardashian is delving further into
the acting World she'll be producing and
starring in a comedy called the fifth
wheel after her role on American Horror
Story so Kim will produce and star in an
upcoming female driven comedy titled the
fifth wheel which is being scripted by
Paula pel and Janine brido deadline
reported on Sunday she has been Hands-On
in the pitching for the film and even
has attended each meeting to deliver her
pitch she has you know multiple
accolades to her name but appears she
has swayed Hollywood as multiple studios
are lining up to get in business with
her according to the site well the
reception from American Horror Story has
been really great for Kim people were
really Shook at how like seriously she
took the acting and and how convincing
she was like they said she was good uh
this article says she's received both
praise and criticism I think there were
also people that's just because and
there's always going to be haters no but
like I saw I watched like a whole
episode on Tik Tok in like in 10
different clips you know and she really
was like giving actress I mean her role
was literally Chris Jenner so I feel
like she'd been mentored her whole life
for this role but I think she impressed
a lot of people I think the show
probably did really well cuz people
tuned in like just out of sheer
curiosity like to see Kim being so
serious but comedy is hard like I would
say that comedy is probably the hardest
thing to act if you're not like a
naturally funny person yeah so I'd be
interested to see this but she's
producing and starring I don't know
about
starring she's producing and d and
starring yeah sorry star but what does
that mean is she the star or she's in it
I don't know but it's like to be funny
is is very hard yeah I just like she's
so much going on like why do you want to
be an actress I no like why do you care
about this right no it's definitely like
I understand her her motivation and her
energy to like be the best in business
the best in influencing the best in
fashion like I get it this is so random
and like she doesn't need Hollywood and
I feel like all this time they always
would be like you know when people like
would trash the show they they would be
like you know well we're not actresses
we're not winning any Oscars here and
it's like and now that's what you want
to be no it's a good
point I just I don't get it I feel like
yeah it's random yeah but you know I
love a female driven comedy when it's
done well so I'm open-minded I don't
know female driven comedy gives like
cringe energy but we'll have to see it
does but it could you know in theory be
good it could like a female driven
comedy is like Bridesmaids like one of
the funniest best movies probably ever
made for women by women for everyone but
like female driven comedy like sounds
like a flop no but like think about like
uh Amy Schumer like train wreck or yeah
no that's like that's the good like the
best of the best when it's good it's
good yes yes yes so I'm
openminded what do you think is a better
movie train wreck or I feel
pretty so tough I I feel like train
wreck like for sure
but not enough people talk about I feel
pretty like I I I walked out that movie
and was like I feel so like seen like I
laughed but I also felt like empowered
empowered and like this was a film like
literally about me no it actually was no
I know like I Fel I never felt saw
myself felt myself so like literally
represented in a movie yeah it was
really good but I agree train rack is
better so good luck Kim and our fifth
and final story is a little more acting
news Okay Megan Markle uh commented on
the suits Resurgence she says it's wild
that suits is breaking streaming records
four years after it ended I can't
believe Megan margar like went to an
event you know yes she went well she
went to the power of women variety
events so she's going to go to any event
like that sounds like one she would go
to yeah and uh she was asked about the
show you know
breaking whatever it did I'm 45 billion
minutes stream too tired to come up with
Recaps the fact she said isn't that wild
she said although she admitted to having
no idea why it's had a Resurgence she
remembered filming the show with joy
quote it was great to work on such a
great cast and crew we had a really fun
time I was on it for Seven Seasons so
quite a bit but it's hard to find a show
you can binge watch that many episodes
these days so many maybe that so that
could have had something to do with it
but good shows are
Everlasting yeah no she's right like
there it's built to binge it's like
seven seasons maybe even nine actually
20 episodes they don't make that like
that anymore it's 30 minute shows that
are 10 episodes a season like right so
it's a really bingeable show it's a good
show and of course like the cultural
relevance of Megan Markle is an
important factor in it as well but I
watch this interview it's so crazy to
see her just like out and about like
like just being like she she walked
right past the Entertainment Tonight
girl and the Entertainment Tonight girl
like asked the question about suits and
she like wanted to answer it so she
walked back and was like here's what I
think and she would seemed really um
like excited about the fact that
everybody was watching it like she like
she has wanted to address this oh good
and she found her opportunity good I'm
glad she enjoyed like it's a win for
everyone people liked watching it like
watching her she liked that for them she
wore a neutral tone dress which I feel
like is so her aesthetic she never like
really steps out of like her kind of
like what I'm wearing today like very
Coastal Grand neutral tones very Jenny
Kane Nancy Meyers yeah she looked great
she looked great Harry was not there I
don't think so I didn't see him in the
pictures or anything plus was power of
women oh yeah I'm just like so over him
I I like love when she leaves the house
without him like leave him at home he
seems like so
Miz I feel like she's like this Ray of
life but like that's why she has to like
get him out of the house I know but it's
like AAR she like like they said Marco
Sparkle like that totally comes through
every time I watch an interview like she
definitely is this like joyous ray of
light and I feel like he's just this
miserable [__] like I know but like
she's
his wife like she has to like try and
you know cheer you there there in lies
the issue like I honestly you don't
think she should be his wife anymore I'm
just over him like for real like I I I
really don't like him okay but do you
think that she should still be his wife
like technically I would say yes but I
just love when she steps out without him
like I need her to go to like more
girl yeah I need her to like go out with
beyon seren Williams like I need her to
like do more on her own because I really
do and I genuinely believe this like I
do believe he brings her down
yeah but they could also like do a
couple things together like no I'm not
interested I also feel like she like
they they moved to like
her country he no and like let's be real
now like he [__] up that whole thing
like I think a lot like a lot of her
misery I do believe like my takeaway
from that documentary was his fault H
her misery in the UK yeah so it's like
you know what you put me through that
[__] we're moving to LA right right no
but I think they're moving to LA and
like quitting the family and all that
was like his way of like overcorrecting
for initially like not giving her the
tools that she needed when she was there
sure no so what you're saying is like
she's indebted to him and fine but like
no not that she's indebted she's got to
shake him she's got to shake that
miserable [__] if she just like left him
no I don't think she can leave him but I
think she really needs to start like
being like a gallab out town alone it
seems like this week she has the same
idea she
wasited paparazzi pics in like random
places where like you know the paparazzi
weren't like just lurking so I feel like
she's decided to put herself out there
yeah she she's wallowed with him I just
feel like he's like a miserable person I
feel like she wallowed with him like
enough I miss my family like [__] off
and now like she can fly that's really
how I
feel okay I yeah I feel like they're in
like a different stage now like I don't
know what's next for them but she was
also postpartum for a while so I
understand her being like low-key for
the last couple of years no yeah she's
back in the game right and I need to see
like weekly sightings
alone I agree with weekly sightings they
don't have to be alone but the alone are
fun no they really do also the crown is
out only like the first the first half
of it and then the rest comes out in
December I think I'll just wait oh for
sure I heard they were amazing we should
watch on our trip yes I meant to call
you over the weekend and tell you that
to add it to our list okay good cuz I
won't have time to watch it um before
then anyway so perfect so those with the
fast five those were pretty good yeah
you needed to know them that's what's
going on in
harleywood
hurwood
harleywood and that is our show for
today we're back tomorrow reminder that
our merch is now available for a limited
time our wenmi Christmas collection is
available at shop toast
merch.com uh all sizes are available for
a limited time make sure to get your
orders in we'll be closing the shop
probably tomorrow or Wednesday to make
sure everybody can get their orders as
soon as possible so thank you so much
for listening to the toast Millenia
morning show where we deliver the fast
five stories you need to know every
Monday through Friday on YouTube so if
you're watching us on YouTube please to
subscribe and give this video a thumbs
up we're also available as podcast any
podcast we found so Spotify public video
cast all the plac listen podcast find us
the toast star you better a beautiful
sunning and wickedly talented we are
hope you guys have an amazing day and we
will see you tomorrow love you
bye